i
[Música]
ah
alrededor de 2 millones de niños mueren
antes de nacer en el mundo anualmente
según un informe en conjunto de la oms y
unicef el banco mundial y naciones
unidas el informe dice también que el
84% de estas muertes se produce en
países de bajos recursos y muchos de
ellos están aquí en el áfrica
sub-sahariana algunos de estos países en
el continente son guinea bissau
república centroafricana y sudán del sur
que registran el mayor número de casos
62 países en el mundo sin embargo no
pudieron dar cifras porque no tienen
capacidad de hacer seguimiento a esa
problemática de manera que ésta sigue
siendo una crisis bastante
invisibilizada lado ms advierte también
que las consecuencias de la pandemia en
el sistema de salud de algunos de estos
países podría significar en un aumento
de muertes hasta entre un 11 y un 20 por
ciento según lo que dice el informe la
oms se dice también que es muy
importante fortalecer las capacidades de
auxiliar de enfermería y de parteras
tradicionales en países como nigeria
iluso de parteras tradicionales podría
reducir el alto número de muertes que se
producen durante el alumbramiento que
según el informe representa el 40 por
ciento de las cifras de mortandad
[Música]
oriente medio y asia central
especialmente afganistán es uno de los
lugares donde hay mayores conflictos en
el planeta y esto afecta directamente en
la atención que se le da a las mujeres
embarazas brazadas si bien la situación
de la muerte de niños antes de nacer no
es tan grave como en el áfrica
sub-sahariana y otros países de asia
como incluso nepal o pakistán si es
bastante crítica especialmente en esos
países donde la guerra se hace mayor y
donde la pobreza también es mayor como
en yemen y en afganistán esto hace que
muchas mujeres tengan dificultades para
acceder a centros de salud que ya están
bastante deteriorados por el conflicto
pero además muchas de ellas viven en
áreas rurales donde es difícil acceder a
unos centros de salud que además empeora
por la cultura tradicional de sants de
muchas de esas tribus que no tienen en
la cultura de que las mujeres sean
atendidas cuando tienen estos problemas
durante la maternidad
[Música]
en los últimos años en nicaragua la
mortalidad neonatal contribuye
aproximadamente el 73 por ciento de las
muertes en menores de un año según datos
de la organización panamericana de la
salud que revela que estas muertes
rondan arriba de los mil niños cada año
según el gobierno de nicaragua informó
el año pasado que gracias a una
estrategia de capacitación a una red
comunitaria de enfermeras y parteras
asimismo como capacitaciones al personal
médico en todo el país logró reducir la
mortalidad infantil de 1.700 muertes
en 1500 representando un 6 por ciento de
la reducción asimismo informó que las
muertes en neonatales las redujo en 4.3
por ciento aunque no brindaron mayores
datos al respecto según datos de la
organización panamericana de la salud de
cada 10 muertes neonatales 8.5 están
vinculadas a causas que pueden ser
prevenibles
[Música]